the agenda is said hello everyone I'm
Brent Goff in Berlin America torn apart
again over race and guns is just as
something in the eye of the beholder
there that and more today it's time to
talk Trayvon Martin and George Zimmerman
both American tragedies products of a
society that will not control its guns
and seems unable to heal its racial
wounds is that the America of Barack
Obama well justice on trial in the US
and also in Russia this week we get the
verdict in a trial that some say is
designed to snuff out a vocal critic of
the Kremlin Alexei Navalny is an enemy
of Russian President Vladimir Putin his
future as a political leader could be
decided this week today we asked if
Navalny is about to become a casualty of
the system he wants to change and the
NSA spying story creating scandal here
in Germany it appears the Americans have
been able to spy on Europe with lots of
European help shocked in Germany reports
that the country's intelligence services
worked with the NSA to collect data on
people right here even the German
Chancellor has asked Washington to
respect German law as it sneaks through
the data sphere well I've invited three
people today to talk argue and pry apart
these headlines my first guest is a
Berlin government insider when it comes
to high-tech spy he's been on the show
before I'm happy to welcome again Zandro
gankin he's an advisor to the German
government on cyber warfare he's our
point man today on the NSA scandal and
what it means here in Germany it's good
to have you on the show again Sam job my
second guest knows all too well how
rough Russia can be for political
dissenters she had to leave the country
I am happy to welcome Anastasia ribbit
chenko a Russian opposition activist and
she is our expert today to talk about
what is going on in Russia on the stage
it's good to have you on the show as
well and my next guest has been busy
trying to understand what the names
Trayvon Martin and George Zimmerman tell
us about American Society I'm happy to
welcome to the show Baron Picard he is
editor at the foreign desk with the tots
a newspaper here in Berlin and we're
going to be talking with you bearing
about what this trial and the verdict
what it means about American society the
United States has an african-american
president it is the modern melting pot
seen as a role model for much of the
world so why does it feel like we are
back in the 20th century last weekend's
a not guilty verdict for George
Zimmerman has unleashed anger and
protest african-americans are saying
that they are second-class citizens in
the eyes of the law and if you are happy
to carry a gun many say the courts are
on your side Trayvon Martin died in
February 2012 after a violent
confrontation with George Zimmerman
Zimmerman who had set up a neighbourhood
watch scheme to address crime near his
home saw Martin passing and called
police to say he suspected him of
criminal intent he says Martin
subsequently attacked and injured him so
Zimmerman fired his gun in self-defense
Zimmerman's detractors have called him a
racist vigilante who killed Martin
because he was african-american anger
has also been directed at the police who
initially failed to arrest Zimmerman
saying they accepted his claim that he
had acted to protect himself florida
state laws have also been criticized
they allow people who fear for their
lives to use deadly force without even
trying to flee a confrontation after the
not guilty verdict community leaders
called for nonviolent protests
but across the u.s. there is still
outraged that a 17 year old boy was shot
dead and no one has been held
accountable bear let me pick up with you
on this story how are you explaining
this story to your audience I mean how
should the world understand what is
happening in the US right now well I
think it's a mixture of different
factors one being the gun laws that
almost everybody who wants to intense
too can have a gun and carry it even
then it's the Stand Your Ground law in
Florida which as we just heard allows
you to defend yourself if you just feel
threatened you don't have to prove that
there was really a threat for your life
but if you just feel threatened then you
can lose use even deadly force and
that's why it was Zimmerman and the
initial investigation which was not
really an investigation wasn't even
arrested after killing of Trayvon Martin
let me let me ask everyone here
Anastasia and zandra I'm you know if you
had to give me you know a couple of
words explaining what this trial and the
verdict means what would you say what's
it about I mean I just wanted I'm going
to see how well informed we are about
what's going on Xander what would you
say it's about like the trial pretty
hard to judge but as a German I mean one
thing that's really disturbing me is
this whole concept of an armed
neighborhood watch I think that's from a
German point of view we're above the
state of law and all these kinds of
things this whole idea having people
without professional education
professional training armed out in the
streets and being able to judge for
themselves if they want to shoot
criminals or not that just seems to be
in tahlir on I think that's a big part
of the problem at least from German
business if we use about gun control
Anastasia what about for you mmm i have
a special viewer i even on the topic of
immigration honestly speaking and I for
example call immigration in Germany
positive immigration especially in
Berlin because immigrants here as a used
to be not too used to be criminals and
it's not like in Russia or in America
because here they have social care
and did not suit to do any crimes and
that is a most important reason to
prevent these problems with criminal
station in Moscow is a little bit
different what's interesting here is
we're not hearing anyone saying anything
and what the main discourse in the
United States right now I'm is about the
fact that Trayvon Martin was an
african-american man how do you explain
barrent this disconnect and once you
leave the United States people don't
talk about race as much as they as
they're talking about guns well actually
we talked about racism in this case
because obviously Travon Martin was on
his way home from a candy store having
bought some candies and soft drink and
was just on his way home in the Iranian
I'd wearing a hoodie and that's
obviously a young black male fitting
into every pattern of so-called criminal
suspect behavior that's why george
simmerman spotted him that's why he
followed him even against the advice of
the police officer and while we don't
know exactly how the violent
confrontation came about because we know
only one side of the story because he on
the other side Trevor multi is dead and
couldn't tell his side of the story but
nevertheless what's very clear is that
racial profiling of Trayvon Martin was
the initial cause of all the tragedy
that unfolded afterwards and that's I
think the big story in America right now
black American effort American friends
of mine right on their Facebook pages
and so on what does what what message
does all this send to my family to my
kids that means they are not safe in the
streets just because of being what they
are black young males in the racial
profiling and I mean the racial
profiling in itself is is something bad
but it it is exacerbated by the fact
that you have people walking around
particularly in Florida who have weapons
that can kill someone if they're
thinking in a racial profiling way is
that being communicated would you say
berent to the world yeah I think so I
mean
most parts of the world have
difficulties understanding the obsession
of Americans with guns we in Germany we
are more or less proud of not having an
armed society but about having police
and security forces being armed and the
rest of society not while there are
always some criminals who have access to
guns in some way that's not a common
thing to have a gun in your house and
nobody thinks of self-protecting by
using a gun in deadly force so this is
one cultural device we have with
Americans but America itself is divided
over that too yeah we have seen all the
discussion over the last couple of
months and after all be the NRA the
National Rifle organization the biggest
lobby organization in washing or one of
the biggest has prevailed and just
having Senate not confirming any and not
passing any of those I was in the United
States the last two weeks and I was in
the US when the verdict came came down
in the Zimmerman case and I talked to a
lot of African Americans particularly
when I was traveling back here to Europe
and what is interesting is I didn't hear
a lot of people talking about the gun
problem they were really fixated on the
racial profiling and the racism that
still exists in America and you know I
threw out a couple of times in
conversations well wouldn't it be an
easier topic racism would it be easier
to deal with if we didn't have the
threat of death walking around with
everyone you know on their belt that
being a gun and when I would use that
logic a lot of people looked at me like
I was Mars and that that disconnect is
so big in the United States and I'm
wondering if that is being communicated
outside of the United States it just how
big that disconnect is I think it's a
little bit what foreign correspondence
German correspondence in the United
States always try to do is somehow
translating American thinking to the
rest of the world because there are
really some differences and
in there the whole relation between
society and government a lot of people
not only a hardcore tea partiers in the
United States think that small
government of the goods thing the
government shouldn't have too much power
and so on and this in part it's a good
thing of course but another part it
leaves society to do whatever it wants
and two self-proclaimed want to be cops
like George Zimmerman it's had to go out
of control indeed kind of of incidents
we saw in the Trayvon Martin yeah I had
a conversation to last weekend you know
I mentioned the fact that if George
Zimmerman had not had a gun on him maybe
Trayvon Martin would be alive today and
I said you know this whole stand your
ground policy and the right to carry
guns everywhere is part of the problem
and what I heard from people saying the
reaction was well you have to be able to
defend yourself and that is something I
never hear here in Europe when people
are talking about security or a mother
talking about society no one is talking
about being your own militia just
because nobody has guns in the first
place right i mean i wouldn't even know
how to get a gun here in Germany I mean
I'd have to do some serious homework and
in the states you know I could go buy
ammunition at Walmart it is a completely
different culture but parent do you
think criminal civil rights charges
should be filed against George Zimmerman
I think it will be hard proof as it was
hard to prove second-degree murder in
the the trial that rest anytin saturday
because after all I mean he has not no
record of being an outspoken racist
white supremacist he is half Latin
American and that has not been it's not
part of the discourse either he is he's
Hispanic he's part hispanic yeah so we
have these minorities that are
intersecting in this now what you have
is you have that completely I mean
there's just two different experiences
one from maybe even really intimidated
why people in neighborhoods fearing for
young black male throughout
their house too and that's a reality too
I mean most of the crimes and robberies
and armed robberies are committed by
young black males so Trayvon Martin just
fit into the pattern but then you have
the prospects perspective of all those
black families just like Barack Obama
said if he had a son it he would look
like exactly like Trayvon Martin and a
friend of mine a black American friend
of mine who wrote the same thing she was
moving 20 years ago with her young son
and that time to a neighborhood that was
before predominantly black white sorry
in Washington DC and she recalls how
many times her kid was stalled mopped in
the street asked by someone who if you
really belong to people calling the
police just because of him being there
and that's the experience a lot of blood
family share and somehow the verdict non
guilty verdict confirms that this is how
it's good to be yeah I mean you know
there are a lot of things coming out of
this verdict I heard in the United
States to a lot of journalists asking
was it possible for an all-female jury
to come up with a rational verdict
because five of the six women on the
jury had children their mothers and they
said so they're going to identify with
trayvon Martin's mother and I was
listening that I found my gosh this is
like this is misogyny here these are
misogynist reporters and they don't even
realize that that was one thing that
came up but I think what people are
taking out of this and this is what I
hear from a lot of people is that
American will only be able to make real
progress and racial relations when it
gets his gun problem under control
because every I mean think about in the
90s we have the Rodney King riots now
we're having protests and it's all about
it's about weapons and violence I even
heard somebody say the airport in New
York American needs to be more European
when it comes to this are you reporting
that
well but that's only one part of the
story I mean there are a lot of
Americans who really don't want to be
like Europeans because they sing Europe
is socialism and it's a control society
and no freedom and so on so I mean
America is a divided country and
politically very polarized Congress done
though to America's image of being a
successful melting pot I I think you
always have this kind of contradictions
you had a lot of success in being a
melting pot because no one is suspected
or has been bally regarded because of
not speaking very fluent English because
a lot of people have an immigrant story
and learn English that's much harder
hear you speak back bad German then
you're we got much worse than you speak
bad english in America but on the other
hand you have all those ethnic groups
suspecting each other the expanding the
blacks the Asian people and some
community is very very well segregated
you have the the the the love American
communities in all the big cities and
the other groups just fearing for their
jobs or and so you have a lot of things
and then you have violence sometimes
gang violence sometimes domestic
violence sometimes criminal violence in
just normal robbery cases in all this is
not a really a success story but it's a
story is that nobody doubts that all
these people are American and that's
what we have in Germany for example
that's foreigners year or so you gotta
fast forward night now I have the idea
for 39 conversation all the time with
taxi drivers here in Berlin they've
lived here all their lives but they
don't feel German before we move on yes
or no is America's image in the world
worse off today because of the Zimmerman
verdict yes or no what do you say Sandra
I'd say no it's probably too ditz it's
in bro it's irrelevant incident but
probably too small to disrupt the
general image of the u.s. stasia no
America always looking the same ok it
looks the same all right well there you
go all right now since we've been
talking about justice and politics in
the u.s. we want to move and talk about
justice and politics in Russia this week
judges are due to announce the verdict
in the trial that could very well
illustrate just how
dangerous it is to dare to criticize the
Putin administration political dissent
could be a one-way ticket to prison in
Russia take a listen Alexei Navalny
faces charges that he conspired to steal
timber an accusation that could bring
him a six year jail term but that is not
the only possible consequence of his
trial if he is convicted even with a
suspended sentence he will be prevented
from taking part in September's election
to become mayor of Moscow Navalny
emerged as a key figure of the
opposition to President Vladimir Putin
in the anti-government street protests
of 2011 his support grew because of his
blog exposing corruption among officials
and he has said he will run for the
presidency in 2018 lets you know what's
the matter must be the case follows that
of sergei magnitsky a lawyer who was put
on trial after he uncovered corruption
he died following brutal treatment while
in custody Magnitsky's conviction last
week for years after his death
symbolizes for many observers what is
wrong with Russia's justice system
Anastasia I mean this is a big week for
Russia is it going to be a good week or
dark week it depends of course on the
sentence for Alexei Navalny and expect
what do you think the verdict is going
to be me sir quite similar to the
situation with real Holocaust key
because he also tried to participate in
election to Moscow Parliament in 2005
and after he was sentenced and after
appeal he just has no head no
possibility to participate as the
selections and there were quite know
there were some people who was against
this sentence it's about some Congress
in Moscow who was organizing action self
protest but it it's not helped him
unfortunately you let's talk a little
bit about your story because I mean you
have a direct connection to what's
with with Navalny I mean you had to
leave Russia tell us a little bit about
why you had to leave Russia we had very
big protests after election to russian
parliament angeles inauguration 2012 it
was before even but after inauguration
situation little bit chest it's a long
story but the most important things that
about 100,000 people fortunately at
least heat up the streets in Moscow it
and I was waiting for that about four
years during my participation these
protests right you you helped organize
these protests against imaginable some
years ago and it's happened yeah finally
and what me why did you feel you had to
leave the country because after the last
my station of six of may I just Russia
government prova cated conflict with
police and the statutory people and
after that they said that was not a
protest it was right and responsible for
that your eyes persons will be arrested
and I understand so you want afraid you
were going to be arrested I'm not afraid
but just not my idea to sit imprisoned
in Russia because I have a lot of useful
things to do and in particular for my
country all right so you wanted to do
you want it to avoid being arrested I
mean you know that's a that's a terrible
at four or five days okay but and then
you left I was 62 Gaza reasonably he was
a near sir camera to me it's a terrible
indictment on your home country that you
feel like you have to leave for your own
safety just because you have protested
against what the government is doing now
of course it's so strange to know that
you really like your country and want to
do something for your country but some
guys from garment think that is a new
know better what is what should be with
Russia but I hope of course I have my
own opinion
how Russia's which kind of Russia should
be which kind of country and this
gassing garments they just have other
opinion and of course I don't like it
because they only care about it on money
and gas and oil and said so and you want
to go back to Russia right I mean I mean
we were talking on your Twitter account
you know you say never asked for asylum
you you want to go back and you want to
help change the country now a lot of
people we're talking about we're all
foreigners here look at Russia and see
it as a big mess and see it being under
the thumb of Vladimir Putin what can
change that and what can change that
peacefully or do you think it can't be
changed peacefully you mean to change
share too after Putin the Putin system I
mean the fact that right well the fact
that if you descent if you criticize the
government bad things can happen to you
for example on that is part of that's
part of the the justice system I mean
people you I think you would agree
that's what happens in Russia when when
people dare to criticize how can that be
taken out of society I mean human rights
how can they be protected without some
type of revolution taking place to
change the system is not so not so easy
and even European Union work a lot about
it but if you will change him exactly
this system of justice I think it's
really long and very hard work and at
first we should change government I
think because people a lot of people
really care about they already not need
to be changed because a lot of Russians
now really has this democratic view but
the problem is that it's like in
Belarusian now because this person who
really has democratic reviews they could
leave Russia and different germany and
f'd saw a lot people who left Russia and
they could stay in change government and
they just should be
sure they will not be arrested for it
okay you you have faith that during the
next elections for example that a
peaceful change of power can take place
that will also bring in changes in how
the justice system is is carried out I
mean do you have faith that democracy
will work in your favor in Russia it
depends on government because really a
lot of people has democratic view and
they don't want to have this kind of
problems with police with justice and so
on because everybody feels that that if
you will be in court you have a lot of
possibilities to be arrested doesn't
matter what you did and a lot of people
understand that was just a problem that
garment has four has red has
possibilities to arrest people to kill
people and it's hard to change for usual
people I mean um Alexei Navalny well you
know he'll get this ruling this verdict
this week and it will decide the rest of
his life I mean he wants to be the next
mayor of Moscow right and he'd also like
to be the next president of russia I
mean he is the big enemy to Vladimir
Putin Vladimir Putin cannot allow him to
get out of this legal process clean
candy because he can't allow Navalny to
come out and be able to run for office
in Moscow and become the mayor of Moscow
right yeah I mean do you think there's
going to be massive protests then if
Navalny is found guilty and is put in
prison and taken out of the political
process in Russia um that should be of
course because it's just unfair what's
going on is here but I think you think
people are going to go out on the
streets i mean i i'm trying to think
there will be some thousands of people
about ten or something like that it's
not enough of course yeah i mean d is it
being talked about in Russia the way
we're talking about it right now are
people talking about Navalny be
a litmus test for the justice system for
the judiciary and for democracy in
Russia are people talking about mr.
joking of course but the Russia is you
know is quite big there are 100 3 and 4
43 / people a million people in there
and not all of them aware of this case
of course and unfortunately but on the
other side firstly Moscow is quite pull
it politically as a city we she
interested in policy and there are a lot
of people who were of this case and just
affect that i don't think that 100,000
people will run the streets once again i
think it only was some sergeants okay so
some thousands um before we move on
Zandro and varun let me ask on both of
you is Russia on a path towards more
democracy or less democracy based on
what we're hearing from Anastasia I
think it's a path to last democracy
because after all after after a decade
of Putin politics the system is so
cemented them and so so fix and I mean
all those cases called a coffee and all
the journalists who were being
intimidated or even killed it's jason
intimidation for everyone else and it's
a clear signal if you show up to
criticize the government then bad things
can happen to you and that works for
time yeah i mean what do you say Xandra
I mean about the role of the German
government shouldn't they be more vocal
in criticizing Putin I mean Anastasia
should not have to leave her home
country she shouldn't have to come to
Germany she should be able to stay in
Russia and protest yeah well but the
situation in Russia is pretty difficult
we always wonder about what what
actually drives the Kremlin to to
generate that much amount of control
because we have that in the security
community as well when you talk to the
people there they're very professional
very good to talk to but the amount of
power and what they're allowed to say is
the term about how close they are to the
Kremlin so there's always a large amount
of control than any of this and we
wonder if that's just the kg
the background of Putin probably the
mentality to run the country this way or
if you really needs this much power and
control to stay in power so and but
anyway it's difficult to to address that
topic because they're very sensitive
about yes obviously and there's a lot of
4 from a diplomatic point of view there
the question is if you address it then
you lose your impact to them and if
you're probably just going going to be a
bit more moderate with them and soft
with them and you're from a real
political point of view you can do more
good for the country than if you're
opposing them exactly but I would you
know I would like if I Nastasia could go
home and not fear for for her safety
when do you think you'll be able to go
home Anastasia then when mm I will try
to do that after my master program here
in Berlin so when is that when like next
year and two years and I'm my bachelor
in Estonia and muster in Germany ho so
we're talking about four five six years
I think three all right okay you fasten
all right what we hope you can
definitely go home and be safe Russian
President Vladimir Putin he is not
holding back and throwing punches at the
US right now he says that US authorities
have trapped fugitive intelligence
leaker Edward Snowden in Russia Snowden
has been offered asylum by several Latin
American countries but he still doesn't
have the papers he needs to leave the
Moscow Airport mr. Putin we wonder of
course what role you have in that well
the spying scandal is rocking Europe as
Snowden tries to plot his next move and
all of this could become a political
bomb here in Germany with just two
months before national elections when
you see ever Edward Snowden claims to
possess thousands of documents showing
the extent of covert surveillance
carried out by the United States the
National Security Agency says it needs
the data to combat terrorism but the
potential uses go much further than that
Snowden believes much of the information
gathering violates both US law and
privacy laws in other countries Germany
has been targeted more than any other
European country Chancellor Angela
Merkel says the US must tell the
government what it's doing
missin good now is the time to seek
intensive dialogue about what's
permissible I'd like to stress the ends
do not justify the means that will be
the German approach in these
negotiations fondles I'm at the same
time intelligence agencies in Germany
and elsewhere are alleged to have known
what was going on they may even have
actively participated in the snooping in
Sandra is is that a surprise or should
it be a surprise to anyone well none of
that has really been a surprise for the
security community we've had these
rumors for years and actually I've been
talking to that about that on talks for
in the past 45 years that this is a
clear option because the technology was
there and the interest was there the law
the laws were there and in in the US and
it was open to the secret services they
would have been stupid if they wouldn't
have done it it's interesting though
Germany is a country where politicians
and the public they place a a high
premium on protecting personal data
personal information and yet at the same
time you have the German intelligence
community working with the NSA to spy
some would say on Germans I mean how do
you how do you reconcile that yeah well
it's a difficult relation but one one
thing I think that is very important for
the German mentality to understand that
is that Germans are very concerned with
the German state doing something like
that to the Germans because that's a
sort of a historical historically
difficult relation but there seems to be
one less outrageous analyst or in
intelligence yeah that does it mean less
if a foreign power if the United States
is doing it yeah absolutely exaggerated
emotionally it seems to be much less
relevant than much much less dangerous
than when the Germans are doing that to
the Germans yeah German Chancellor said
yesterday beginning this week that she
had made it clear to Washington that the
US has to respect German laws as it
continues to spy and I matt said they
have to respect Jeremy laws on German
soil a German so it has a very elegant
formulation because everything they did
they did on the US
so that they don't really have to
respect anything but isn't isn't a
comment like that I mean she's saying a
lot there by not saying much it means
she's saying that Germany accepts the
fact that the u.s. is somewhat of a
benevolent big brother and we know that
the NSA other American security agencies
are spying on us here and we'll let them
do that well there seems to be some some
benevolent tolerance for that kind of
behavior especially because we
apparently we benefited from some of the
terrorists searches they did although
that remains to be proven that's just a
hypothesis which is there now it's
really difficult to judge for the
Germans the Germans are very concerned
with anything the German secret services
do the German police does but they seem
to be much less concerned with foreign
intelligence especially when you get
security outcomes from there it seems to
be an entirely different story also from
from from a legal point of view but also
from an ethical point of view so it's
hard to judge it was hard to judge
because it's before the elections and
how and so of course all the parties are
pretty mad about this right i mean this
is you know they're angry they're upset
about it although they've all been
complicit in it bear do you see this
this NSA story becoming a political hot
potato in September when we have
national elections here I don't think so
actually so I'm so each answer uncle
America she doesn't have anything to
worry about for that no no because after
all I mean first of all even if the
opposition parties try to exploit a
little bit and make incredible critical
points about the the government the trip
of our Minister of the Interior now to
to Washington he was played by the
opposition for not making a good point
and defending driven sovereignty and so
on but after all most people I guess
suspect that with the SPD government and
progressed in exactly the same after all
because nobody would would want to you
to to to to put the cooperation with the
United States and terrorism in the war
on terror at risk just because of
climbing that and most of all most
Germans don't really feel threatened i
mean a lot of friends of mine who
news but they say hey that's what I
always suspected I'm not surprised and I
don't have nothing to have nothing to
hide but I hear that all the time I hear
that here I also hear that on the other
side of the Atlantic people say they
they suspect that their telephone calls
are being monitored their emails are
being monitored but they say if you're
not doing anything wrong what do you
have to hide but it's interesting what
you say it doesn't matter what type of
government you have they're going to go
along with this surveillance and we hear
that in the United States to Obama's got
a lot he's you know gotten a lot of
flack for continuing policies from the
Bush administration so this whole
surveillance world is bigger than any
political direction right and but
doesn't that makes it more permanent I
wonder if that's something that people
should be afraid of I think they should
be and 11 very important to mention
which is not being discussed that much
as the international dimension because
one one thing that happened immediately
after these these things came out with
Snowden was that China Russia who were
always accused by the west of being the
bad guys because they did so much
surveillance on their own Popular's they
said oh so it's not that bad after all
we're not on one of the bad guys anymore
and you're not the good guys anymore
seems that we're all doing the same kind
of stuff and I think that's a very
dangerous signal at the moment because a
lot of other nations were still about to
become information societies get the
signal now at this very point in time
where they decide whether to implement a
lot of surveillance probably some
censorship and things like that but
isn't it seems to be kind of a cave is
it at practice propaganda too isn't it
Sandra I mean no one is saying that the
NSA in the United States is spying on
Americans to to limit their their
freedoms I mean everyone in Congress
Democrats and Republicans say the spine
that is being done is being done to find
terrorism Russia is there the Chinese
say the very same yeah but you know that
the Russians and the Chinese are using
it to a press and limit the freedoms of
their own people and that's the
difference I'm story is the same but the
story is the same and I wonder if that
difference you know
talk about what's being communicated I
mean it's easy to paint the US as the
bad guy here but how you use
surveillance at the end of the day is it
is the most important thing the problem
occurs that term you say they use it but
mostly against for example energies or
channel other states or tears because us
knows it is as fact just a fact they
fightin with this kind of activism and
Russia fighting with democracy that is a
problem and that's why in the America
just stupid to fight against and
democratic activists and if you wrote
his emails or something like other you
should not do anything because it's part
of your system make you've got this kid
you okay that's true you said one reason
why you left Russia is that you knew
your telephone calls were being
monitored right yeah I was calling to
navani and they just checked that I mins
ethic affair and still discover came
about twenty policeman's and one special
police memo from this special committee
for fighting visa so-called extremism
and the rest atone remains at cafe yeah
I mean you know that in itself we see in
what direction all the surveillance can
go in how I can oppress people I'm
wondering what does this mean for the
internet because the Internet seems to
be the the battleground here and there
are a lot of people fighting for the
Internet to remain neutral and to remain
open can it remain that way if it's
going to be the forum where all of this
spying and surveillance takes place it's
about control when you're spying isn't
it well I think the internet is really
one big crater and if you've got the
resources and the interest to exploit
that capability to actually tell you
everything about everyone then you're
just going to do it and that's that's
probably the greatest threat i think in
then and in the long term where it will
develop in the free states free nations
will Democratics the state of law it
will be a marvelous tool for democracy
and how
enriching the discourse but in other
nations more totalitarian characters and
more to leaning towards control it will
be a tool of control and oppression yeah
you know before we wrap things up let's
talk this very briefly about Edward
Snowden how do how do you view him is he
a whistleblower has he done something
good or is he a traitor as he as he
leaked information that he shouldn't
have and you know turned his back on his
own country I think well for us he did
some good because after all it's good
that the public after all knows but
what's being done and not only suspect
that that might be ongoing but from a
legal point of view from the United
States he is clearly traitor so I i want
that he be protected it's a sort of
irony that he's protected by Russia
right now and has some offers of other
states which doesn't have a really good
record on civil rights exactly but
nevertheless after all it comes down to
the enemy of my enemy be my friend and
we are in apple or Oswald again and so
that's very can see so we've got a
minute left Anastasia what do you say
about Russia helping Snowden or giving
him shelter at least I think I Marie
démocratique controversial provides
Ingrassia mizoram asylum you think you
should what do you send him what do you
think is he a traitor or is he a hero
well neither he did some good in putting
this on the agenda and actually giving
us a chance to talk about it once more
and to determine our values and what we
want especially in international
relations and data protection but to me
and to a lot of people working in this
field nothing was really so very
surprising so but from a legal point of
view who seems to be more of a traitor
from a political point of view he did
some good do you think he's paved the
way for other whistleblowers or leakers
even in Germany there's not that much to
to whistleblow in Germany mainly because
we don't have the money to come up with
the such amazing intelligence
capabilities ok so the lack of resources
generates a lack of missiles
it is all about money Xander thank you
very much Anastasia ban thank you all
for being on the show that is gonna wrap
up my agenda this week don't forget you
can watch the show again on our website
and on YouTube and don't be shy tell us
what you think about the show our inbox
is always open you see our address right
there I'm print Gogh in Berlin join me
next time when I set the agenda